welcome to this video playing oops swap
the national master muller one of the
favorite favorite they're one of the
most frequent opponents is playing this
triangle system quite often and I'm
going for this line now this is some a
main reply to that black is playing for
a later c5 freeing up his Bishop and
term white tries to if possible prevent
see 5 or make it difficult for black to
play that
let's see I really have forgotten the
details like probably play something
like a six here or Luke see a door Queen
B 6 and many yeah a successor very
sensible looking move I'm playing a for
to discourage c5 by putting pressure on
the beep on it weakens the Queen side a
little bit but it is more important to
fight against the the key idea check
yeah okay I'm going here so that the
night has ideas or chances chance to go
to be three after Knight c3 this is a a
bit misplaced okay interesting here so
he's aiming for for direct counter play
here on don't don't quite get it yet I'm
going in fat chick here yeah I have to
take it anyway so it's no ID no use in
looking at other stuff so a takes rook
a8 Queen aid we should be five this
Queen a one check
okay this pudding is inserting this
intermediate caption okay no big enjoy
them so yeah one interesting thing is
that maybe there's also Queen f3 and
some some positions okay take hear their
queen f3 because my night is Sam is
pinned
yeah I'm not sure how dangerous that is
though Queen a one I have queen bee one
so that's not a big problem Queen f3
yeah group g1 I there is no other move
then go from there Queen f3 I might
actually castle I can't castle after
them not sure how good it is but it is
at least possible not blundering stuff
immediately yeah I don't know what is
ideas okay I can castle but is it is it
any good yeah is it any good that's it's
difficult
brooktree root g one is the alternative
yeah I don't know the rook here is maybe
not so badly placed there are some
issues here if he let's say castles I
can play seasick oh I thought I can
place this 6 cm I but it is I it's not
so clear actually sure but it's still
Bishop f6 is in the in the mix right c6
or is he going to do something great
like okay one no I thought here and
where's the Queen going now Bishop f
successes is an issue
I don't really know where the queen is
going Bishop f6
check so Queen chicks and then Queen f5
is a possibility while King King takes a
sum is completely strange Queen takes
Queen Queen of 5 that's unfortunately
possible
even 94 then if I still if I take with
the king what is the what is happening
Queen 94
ah what a what a messy position 994 I'm
not convinced about
94 i can go King you won the night kingi
one queen of five then he's sitting in a
in a South pen I really don't know if
this is any good i Knight f3 is the
threat I also can go to see one okay
it's doing something else entirely this
keeps Bishop f6 in the position I can
maybe he wants to go rook c8 I don't
have to have to increase the speed
f4 for Bishop f3
time morning night III Quincy three Wow
impossible for me to to judge this
really out of my out of my ability they
cannot i have no idea what's going on
here I said King f7 actually check check
check check can I somehow play for win I
don't know check going here chat is this
a suicidal I don't know
I know he can take c7 that's stupid and
this this was very stupidly played I
cannot even let me draw a good black
foreheads yeah it was too late yeah I
really hate to win a crappy game like
that on time but I offered offered too
late he couldn't accept any more well
what a what a weird game ya know but he
knew what was going on was it good for
me it was it bad for me who knows ha I
don't really have no idea what a what a
weird game ok I went here and the
computer wants me to castle no but no
idea this is just just a total mess
rucca ATA was very strong winning HOH
black hmm
now it is sat entirely unclear Queen d2
was actually good okay how with this
move okay 95 Bishop d8 and widest patent
that isn't so difficult with him yeah
this is what I must do yeah this was
this was a crazy idea and end it it
really was bad f 494 Bishop e3 this is
this is equal according to the computer
Queen d2 with equality oh yeah okay so
impossible to play correctly grouped and
21 was windy actually chad is this just
the win yeah i mean he's still playing
without the rook but this is not really
a big problem it's got a couple of pawns
and this active queen and here it was
just ask just a check straw jack black
black and win check new horse weighs
shatter check here i can just take the
Queen what am I doing here you can just
take the Queen haha i can just take the
Queen on b3 instead i played this move
which is completely crazy yeah some more
probably queen bee three irritated me so
much because i actually thought okay now
i will take and all of a sudden I
noticed oh I cannot take but I didn't
see that I can take the Queen yeah okay
yeah TM here is of course completely
winning I i offered the draw because i
don't like to win those kind of games he
would easily win with the increment I'm
control but I offered to late so that
actually one on time yeah but what can
you do that okay
messy game I hope it was fun to watch